welcome back i've got lauren graham here
her show is called the mighty ducks game
changers it's on disney plus you should
check it out or you're a loser
um and because i like the show so much
it's time for a game called mighty ducks
or mediocre ducks
[Applause]
all right well we need a host a lord are
you free as a bird kelly
actually maybe birds are as free as me
after all i created them and
you and pretty much everything else you
did a good job when you created me man
yes i do all right well say hello to the
almighty
hi hey how you doing girl remember we
was in evan almighty together
yes yes
so what's up with the game well in this
game i'm going to read a plot line or
quote
now if what i said was from lauren's
show you will buzz in and say
mighty ducks but if it was not from her
show
you will buzz in and say mediocre ducks
because not all ducks were created equal
now kelly you're going to be playing for
the left wing of the audience
and lauren you're going to be playing
for the right wing nice okay
and the winner will get her side a very
very cool prize now there is one more
rule and perhaps the most important
you got to wait until i'm done reading
to hit your button
oh okay i'm looking at you kelly i was
gonna say i know that was for me
okay fine okay here we go here's the
first question okay
this show or movie involved ducks
using an object called the black disc
of death that's you that's my that's
that was her that
that was mighty ducks game changer yeah
i was like that was her that said it
okay that is what lauren's character
i can't believe i'm being here online
okay kelly you got one point
that smells good here's question two
calm down girl now
reign it in okay okay question two okay
this this show or movie
had an old duck named after a gin
who liked to eat cake left over from
kid's birthday party
i had to wait till it was done mighty
docs
it is mighty ducks and of course that's
gordon bombay played by the adorable
emilio estevez he's so cute i love him
i love him question number three this
duck-filled
show or movie had a character who said
rather prophetically i might add and i
know prophets
said today i have a feeling you're going
to fall down
a lot oh damn i think that's also mighty
ducks it's you
it is mighty ducks and you said it
you're the one who said
my reflexes here's the thing you know
what's staring me off and i think you
did this role on purpose
start me off because i have to keep
waiting on you to finish your
long-winded
ways excuses excuses i don't know why
well that doesn't change the fact that
lauren is in there oh come on okay
here's the next one
okay this show or movie had a duck who
said
every duck has his limit and you scum
have pushed me over the line
what what that's not i didn't say that
that's mediocre
it is mediocre what's that and now just
to upset
kelly even more i'm going to offer you
a bonus point with this question this is
for you lauren
okay for a bonus point do you know the
name of that duck
daffy
i'm sorry we were looking for howard the
duck that was the movie howard the duck
now that's a throwback
lord yes here's the next one this show
or movie
involved a duck that lived in a new york
city apartment with roommates that
included a chick
a joey and a chandler
friends i don't know why i didn't say it
yes mediocre ducks and friends is
correct
oh you said chandler yeah you got it
that's right you had a duck
they had a duck oh there was a duck
involved yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
technically
it counts and a monkey sure why not
yeah yeah i won here's your next
question
okay this show or movie involved a plot
to sneak into a building
to heist some of the sticks and blades
from a lost room
owned by a bunch of ducks
yes that's you i did that
you know distracted the lady i watched
the show
[Laughter]
i'm just oh that quack that quack bell
means that this is the last question
wait
oh but okay is it and this one is worth
five
bills so whatever you do don't
duck it up that's a little god joke
that's a god joke for you kind of like
the duckbill
platypus okay here's the last one
in this show or movie a mama duck went
into the middle of a cold pond
yelled at a bunch of other ducks and
then went home and ate cheese puffs
oh that's you that was you and you were
angry
because of the rude moms and dads that's
mighty ducks game changer
the winner is kelly this is unbelievable
it's an upset you know for a minute i
was like i didn't like cheese puffs and
mighty ducks did i
you didn't eat a lot in gilmore girl i
watched every show of that too
i actually started that over it's such a
good show um that means that all the
left side of the house
um y'all win because i'm the winner but
because of niacin it's my show
so does the right side everyone get
surprised
all right it's american girl's 35th
birthday and they're reintroducing the
six original characters that started it
all
samantha kirsten molly felicity addie
and josefina
they come in their original outfits
authentic accessories and the first book
in the series
and everyone in the house seats is
getting a 300 gift card to american girl
dolls
my daughter would freak out over that a
big hand she tried
lauren graham everybody
the mighty ducks game changers is now
streaming on disney plus
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure